well Chick-fil-A is a [__] amazing
world because Chick-fil-A owns the dirt
the building and they own the business
and so then they partner with what they
call operators like their franchisees
but they're not franchisees because they
can fire you and all you have to do is
put ten thousand dollars in and they
pick out of like 10 000 applicants a
year for like a hundred spots it's a
two-year betting process you have to
have already worked at a Chick-fil-A for
like three to five years in order to be
qualified for it the sales I think it's
it's over 4 million per location I think
it's 4.8 here's what's even crazier they
have better mortgages than any other
franchise and so since they own the dirt
and the land of the building the
business pays them back right because
they lease it and then corporate gets a
15 rip on Top Line in food and then they
split 50 50 The Profit with the operator
after they took off all the top boy the
average operator makes 200 000 a year
but they're making 15 on that and then
half of the excess profit 700 000 a year
off Top Line and then the other two so
they're making like 900 000 a year per
location not including the mortgage the
appreciation on the building everything
Chick-fil-A did the slow and steady and
now they're [__] unbeatable